قال المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان ان من
الاكاديميين الشورى قتيلا في مدينه حمص في
اول حادثه من نوعها منذ شهر الثوره
السوريه قبل اكثر من سته اشهر وبينما تثير
عمليه الاغتيال تساؤلات حول ابعاد
وتداعيات استهداف هذه الفئه من المجتمع
السوري تبادلت السلطه والمعارضه الاتهامات
حول حالفه القتل هذا
ام
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين
هل يمثل استهداف الاكاديميين او
الاكاديميين المعارضين هل يمثل تحولا في
تعامل النظام مع الاحتجاجات وما هي ابعاد
وتداعيات مثل هذه الحادثه على مسار الدوره
السوريه المتمسكه بسلميتها
ومعنا في هذه الحلقه من بيروت
الكاتب الصحفي فيصل عبد الساتر
وكذلك ينضم الينا من لندن الكاتب الصحفي
السوري المعارض بشاره
اذن نرحب بضيفنا وابدا معك اه الاستاذ عبد
الساتر ما مغزى او اه اه كيف نفهم هذا
الاستهداف المباشر
الاكاديميين بعد استهداف الاطفال والفتيات
اختطاف الفتيات الان اه استهدافها
الاكاديميين كيف يمكن في اي اطار يمكن اه
يعني اولا تفضلتي في مقدمه ال الحلقه
والبرنامج قلت ان اه الثوار في سوريا او
المحتجون في سوريا تمسكوا بسلميتهم
الوقائع التي تجري في سوريا لا تكشف عن
هذه الوقائع ابدا على الاطلاق ليس هناك
سلميه بل اصبح هناك عنف منظما يمارس على
كل فئات المجتمع السوري سواء من الجيش او
الشرطه او المدنيين او النساء او الاطفال
او الاكاديميين في اليومين الماضيين هذا
يعني حال من اثنين اما ان السلطه تقتل
ابنائها وتقتل شعبها بهذه الطريقه وهذا
امر يعني غير مقبول وغير معقول وغير منطقي
على الاطلاق واما ان هؤلاء الذين يتحركون
في الشارع السوري باقي عليهم الخناق لم
يعودوا يعني يستطيعوا ان يقلبوا الراي
العام او ان يضمن وان هناك تحركا شعبيا
يمكن ان يمثل ضغطا على السلطه في سوريا
ممكن ان يشكل اعتداءا به امام الراي العام
الاخر في العالم العربي او الدولي الى
اخره لذلك ربما لجؤوا الى هذا الاسلوب
الذي يزرع الخوف والبلبله ويعمل على
انشقاقات في
مع السوري وربما هذه تكون من احد الاهداف
الذين يمارسون هذا الفعل سواء كان هؤلاء
من الذين يعني يمثلون خطا معينا في
اتجاهات المعارضه المختلفه ام انهم من
الطابور الخامس الذي يعني اه دائما تزرع
به في مجتمعاتنا العربيه
وطبعا هذا ليس من فراغ وانما من وقائع
معينه هناك مجموعات منظمه القت ال ال
الاجهزه الامنيه السوريه القبض عليهم
وهؤلاء يعني ربما ايضا بعضهم من السوريين
وبعضهم من جنسيات مختلفه اه ربما ستكشف
عنه الايام القليله المقبله بمؤتمر لاحد
المسؤولين السوريين وهذا الامر يعني ليست
ادعاءات وانما وقائع ممكن ان تعلن للراي
العام اما ما يشكله هذا الاستهداف من خطر
على اه على الامن في سوريا انا في رايي
هذا تكرار او استنساخ للنموذج العراقي
بشكل او باخر هذا النموذج الذي قدم الينا
مع الاحتلال الامريكي للعراق ويعني زرع
الفتنه بين ابناء المجتمع الواحد قصر
المجتمع الى فئات دينيه و طائفيه ومذهبيه
وعشائريه في بعض الاحيان ربما الان يحلو
لهم هؤلاء ان يلعبوا في سوريا على الطريقه
التي لعب فيها في العراق
الجمعه في لندن اطراف تحاول ان تسقط في
الماء العكر كما يقول فيصل ها بالساتر الى
اي مدى هذا الكلام مقنع برايك
ان هذا الكلام غير مقنع على الاطلاق هذه
الجرائم المدانه لا تختلف كثيرا او قليلا
عن الجرائم جرائم الحرب التي يرتكبها
النظام منذ اليوم الاول لاندلاع الثوره
انا اسال انا اذا تجاوزنا الشكل ماذا
تختلف هذه الجرائم عن جريمه قتل وتقطيع
اوصال الشهيده زينب الحصني
وماذا تختلف عن جريمه قتل اخيه ماذا تختلف
عن جريمه التازيم اصابع الصديق على ماذا
تختلف عن جريمه قتل غياث مطر بالطريقه
البشعه التي تم قتله فيها ماذا تختلف عن
قصف الرصد ان اليوم بالطائرات اذا كان
هناك او اشخاص مستهدفون فكيف يتم قصف
منطقه بكاملها بالطائرات كيف ماذا تختلف
عن جريمه قصف المخيم في اللاذقيه والزوارق
البحريه يعني الجرائم ترتكب ليس الان ولكن
منذ اليوم الاول الانتفاضه يعني هم يقتلون
الناس انا اقول لك الان ما الذي قاله
فاروق وليد المعلم خمس في الامم المتحده
تحدث عن التعايش بين مكونات المجتمع
السوري بينما نتحدث نحن عن مواطنه عن دوله
المواطنه نحن لا نميز بين سوريا و اخر هم
هددوا اهل السويداء العشائر ويهدد واخوتنا
المسيحيين بال بال اصوليين او بيلعبوا
ورقه الطائفيه ياتون اب اهالي القرى الى
المدن
من خلال عصابات الشبيحه يخلقوا فتنه
طائفيه ولكن
الحماه هم يحاولون ان تعاد عن الفتنه نحن
نحاول كسب الشوارع وليس خساره الشوارع
نحاول كسب اخوتنا من الذين لم ينضموا بعض
الى الثوره يعني اول امس قتلوا ايضا بنفس
الطريقه الدكتور حسن طيب الدكتور الجراح
النشاط السياسي الهام قتلوه بنفس الطريقه
وفي منطقه مزدحمه بالامن وب الحواجز
الامنيه كيف يبررون هذه التصرفات يعني
مجلس حقوق الانسان هو الذي تحدث عن ارتكاب
جرائم ضد الانسانيه
وليد المعلم يقول ان المجتمع الدولي الدخل
هو يعتقد اننا نعيش في غابه وانه ليس من
حق في ظل وجود قانون ان يطالب بحمايه
المدنيين نحن ندرك تماما ان النظام يسعى
الان الى هدفها الامور باتجاه الفتنه
الطائفيه اتجاه عسكري الانتفاضه ولكن
النظام لن يفرح ابدا ثورتها سلميه وفي كل
يوم نقول في الشارع 111
نعم يعني بالتاكيد تثير
تساؤلات حول اه ابعادها
وتداعيات استهداف هذه الفئه من المجتمع
سنحاول ان نتعرف على ملابساتها واهدافها
في هذا التقرير الذي نتابعه الان
بمعنى النظام السوري في بطشه مع اسرار
المتظاهرين على تحدي التي ق معه ومواصله
الصمود في احتجاجهم المستميت الذي احال
الارض السوريه نار الحرب النظام
وضع يدفع النظام كما يقول منتقدو لتجاوز
كافه الخطوط الحمراء وطنيا وانسانيا في
سياق محاولته المستمره للتخلص من مازقه
الحل مع الحسنه الواضحه الامني ما يسميها
العصابات المسلحه بارتكاب ما تثبت الصور
بوضوح قويه مرتكبيه بيد ان اخطر ما يقلق
منتقدي النظام ما يقولون انها محاولاته
المستميته فجر الثوره الى المستقل الطائفي
باستهداف رموز من بعض الطوائف ومحاوله
الايحاء بان عناصر من طائفه اخرى متورطون
في استهدافهم وفي هذا السياق را المنتفضون
حدث في اغتيال الاكاديميين ل الدخيل ومحمد
علي عقيل يوم الاثنين في محافظه حمص
فبينما قدم المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
المعارض الفقيدين باعتبارهما قياديين في
المعارضه انتقد النظام مرارا وبشده امام
تجمعات عديده في الايام الماضيه حول
التلفزيون السوري تقديم هما باعتبارهما
ضحايا للعصابات الارهابيه كف القدر
المسؤول عن كل الشرور في سوريا هذه الايام
من وجهه نظر النظام ولم ينسى التلفزيون
الرسمي التركيز على صفتي القتيلين المهنيه
الراهنه للتدليل ربما على انهما كان على
راس عملهم ا في السلك الرسمي حتى لحظه
اغتيال هما
استجد ضابط برتبه عميد ركن ودكتور في
كليات العماره ب حماس برصاص مجموعات
ارهابيه مسلحه
وفق مراقبين فان اهتمام التلفزيون السوريه
الزايد حسب وصفهم بالاكاديميين القتيلين
هدفه اثاره نعرات طائفيه
كما من كما حدث في محافظه حمص ذاتها منتصف
يوليو تموز المنصرم حينما اتهموا معارضون
الحكومه باغتيال ثلاثه شبان من الطائفه
العلويه وتسريب معلومات تفيد بان نسب انا
من الطائفه السنيه هم المسؤولون عن قتلهم
وال عده السوريه في اول جمعه تلك الحادثه
وهي التي حملت شعار الوحده الوطنيه تاكيدا
فتح مثل هذه المخططات
نعود الى نقاشنا الان والى اه فيصل عبد
الساتر في بيروت استمعت الى بسام الجاره
الذي تحدث قبل قليل عن دفع الوضع دفعا من
طرف النظام نحو عسكره الثوره نحو الحرب
الاهليه والطائفيه دعني انقل لك ايضا في
هذا السياق ماذا تقول الغارديان
البريطانيه
اه تقول اه ان الصراع في سوريا يبدو انه
يتحول الى مرحله جديده محفوفه بمخاطر جمه
لا حدود لها تتمثل في عسكره الثوره ما
مصلحه النظام في احداث فوضى في احداث اه
اه او تحويل اه اه اه هذه الثوره الى
عسكرتها بما قد يؤدي الى تفاقم خطير جدا
للوضع في سوريا
يعني هذا السؤال لا يسال عنه النظام في
سوريا يسال عنه الذين يدفعون ب هؤلاء
الذين يرتكبون المجازر في المجتمع السوري
الى ان يسالوا ما هي الاهداف الحقيقيه من
وراء فعلتهم في سوريا ما هو المطلوب هل هو
المطلوب اسقاط سوريا باي ثمن يعني تجيش كل
وسائل الاعلام العربيه وغير العربيه تجيش
كل مؤسسات حقوق الانسان في العالم كل
المؤسسات الديبلوماسيه وكان لا شيء يحدث
في العالم العربي وما يحدث في سوريا ثم
يقال ان السلطه في سوريا هي تدفع الامور
باتجاه النعرات الطائفيه
انا اسال هل كان احد يعرف قبل هذه الاشهر
القليله التي تمر بها سوريا من كان علويا
او من كان سنيا في المجتمع السوري هل كان
هناك احد يعلم اذا كان هذا جنديا او
مسيحيا هل كان احد يعلم اذا كان داود
راجحه رئيس الاركان الجديد الذي عين وزير
الدفاع من اي طائفه هو في المجتمع السوري
انا اعتقد ان هذا المرض الذي بدا بدات
تغذيه بعض وسائل الاعلام وبعض المغفلين
سيطر على الاغلبيه اه الاعتداء المستمر
على الاطفال اختطاف الفتيات تقطيع اوصال
ال ال ال الاطفال والفتيات واه يعني ال
الان اغتيال مثقفين واكاديميين الا يؤدي
كل هذا الى انفجار في الوظائف قد لا يمكن
احتواؤه فيما بعد
سيدتي انت تتحدثين او كانك تقبض على زمام
الحقيقه وان هؤلاء الذين يقتلون حتما
قتلهم الجيش السوري من قال هذا الامر هل
يعقل هل يعقل ان الجيش السوري سوف يقتل
اطفال ال اه الشعب السوري او يقول نساء
الشعب السوري انا قلت انا لم يتهم
المعارضه بانها هي التي تفعل بالمعنى
الحرفي للكلمه لكن اقول عندما تدمر المنظم
من له مصلحه في قتل الاطفال الذي يجيز على
سوريا في كل الوسائل الاعلاميه الذي له
مصلحه في ان يركع سوريا على مستوى القرار
السياسي في الذي له مصلحه في ان ينتقل من
سوريا على المواقف السياسيه الذي له مصلحه
في ان يفقد مسار التحالف السوري الايراني
عن تحالف المقاومه وفي لبنان وفي فلسطين
وفي العراق كل هؤلاء هم المستفيدون الذين
يحاولون ان يعدوا العده في كل يوم يخرجون
علينا باخبار واكاذيب في حين ان مراسل
الجزيره انترناشيونال الذي جال في كل
الارجاء السوريه تكلم بشكل واضح على ان
هناك عملا عن فيه منظمه يستهدف من خلالها
الجيش وعناصر النظام وعناصر الشرطه
والان تحول الى شيء اخر تماما الذي يعلم
ما يجري في حمص هو يعرف تماما ان هذا الذي
يجري ليس من فعل النظام وانما هذه الافعال
تجري على رجال النظام في حمص تجري على
رجال الشرطه في حمص يقتل من الشرطه ومن
الامن في كل يوم لكن الدوله تحاول ان تهدد
فروع المواطنين حتى لا تذهب في لعبه زرع
الخوف في الا داخل المجتمع السوري ثم يخرج
علينا السيد اشعار او غيره من الشخصيات
الاخرى الذين لا يريدون الا ان يسقط هذا
النظام حتى لو كان على نهر من اه بان دماء
الشعب السوري من قال ان النظام في سوريا
كان يدفع الامور باتجاه الطائفيه من كان
يعلم ان هناك في الطائفيه في سوريا هذا
الكلام لم نسمع به الا ما عندما ت
الامريكي الى العراق الا ما عندما اتى
الاوروبي الى العراق الذي يحاول ان يزرع
الفتن كما زرعها في العراق قسم المجتمع
العراقي الى سنه وشيعه واكراد وصابئه
ومسيحيون وقد وجه المسيحيون الان تجري نفس
المحاوله من جديد بعد ان يئسوا من كل
المحاولات السابقه في ان تتحول الانتفاضه
والاحتجاج في سوريا الى ثوره عارمه والى
حركه
يقول عجز عجزت هذه الثوره اه يعني عن عن
تحقيق هدفها ونحن فعلا نلاحظ ان هناك عجز
عن اسقاط على مدى سبعه اشهر تقريبا عجز عن
اسقاط النظام السوري نظام الاسد او على
الاقل اجبار هذا النظام على الجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات ما هي الاسباب لماذا
برايك
يعني انا اختلف معك كثيرا في هذه النقطه
النظام هو الذي عجز منذ اشهر يبشروننا
بالقضاء على الانتفاضه هم يقولون منذ
الاسبوع الاول انها انتهت منذ شهر قالوا
ان انتهت وقبل العيد قالوا انها انتهت
والان يقولون انها ستنتهي الشعب الذي
انتهى المظاهرات عام مختلف المدن السوريه
رغم التقطيعات الامنيه انا اقول الان لولا
قوه الشارع ما هو مبرر قصف المدن
بالدبابات ما هو مبرر القصف المدن
بالمدافع هل يستهدفون معارضا او شخصا
معينا عندما يقصفون الطائرات انا اقول ان
هذا الالتزام له تاريخ طويل بالاغتيالات
في بيروت من اغتال وليد جنبلاط ما قتل
محمد عمران انا استطيع ان اضعف اللائحه
اربعين شخصا اخر هذا النظام له تاريخ عريق
جنرال الايراني تسمى قال امامكم امر واحد
اما ان تقبلوا بالنظام والا في الحرب
الطائفيه
نحن تعلمنا الطائفيه من تلفزيون الدنيا
مندسين شعبان التي تحدثت طائفيا منذ اليوم
الاول هم يتحدثون عن الطائفيه وهم يحرضون
فشل الحل الامني يعني بدو يستلم
نهايه النظام و لكنهم الان يحاولون اختراع
اوراق اخرى يحاولون عسكره الانتفاضه
يحاولون اللعب بالورقه الطائفيه يخوفون
الناس من بعضهم نحن نحاول الان كل الشوارع
ليس لنا مصلحه لاستهداف اي شخص الجميع
اخوتنا والجميع اهلنا وهم يعرفون ذلك
ولذلك حاله الافلاس هي التي تجعل النظام
يلعب هذه الورقه الحقيقه ورقه الطائفيه
وهي ورقه مفروضه ولم تنجح ابدا يعني الناس
في الشارع ان يقدم الماء والزهور الجيش
فقتلوه
الامثله كثيره ما قتل النساء يعني من يقتل
من المعارضه تقصف الجيش بالطائرات
طيب اه س نتساءل بعد الفاصل عن ابعاد
وتداعيات حادثه اغتيال الاكاديميين
واستهداف المثقفين بشكل عام اه على مسار
الثوره السوريه المتمسكه حتى الان
بسلميتها سنعود اليكم بعد الفاصل فلا تذهب
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد الى حلقتنا
التي تتناول ابعاد وتداعيات الاستهداف
اثنين من الاكاديميين السوريين اتحول اليك
في بيروت فيصل عبد الساتر يعني الان مسار
ال الثوره السوريه وان كانت كما ترى
الغارديان اخفقت في اسقاط نظام الاسد الا
انها يعني كشفت عن وجه وسلوك حضاري للشعب
السوري هذه الثوره ما زالت سلميه حتى الان
الى اي مدى يمكن للنظام السوري ان يستمر
في نهجه الامني في مقاومه ومواجهه ثوره
تتسم بالسلميه
يعني هناك اصرار على جعل الامر وكانه فقط
من طرف واحد في الساحه السوريه او لا لا
اوافق على ان هذه الثوره السوريه نعم هناك
حركه احتجاج نحترم هذه الحركه لها معايير
لها اه مطالب معينه ونحن ندعو الى اجراء
حوار حقيقي وان يكون هناك زمان لهذه
المبادره الحواريه وان تنتهي لما فيه خير
الشعب السوري برمته وان يكون هناك يعني
الحصول على مطالب وجيهه ومحطه للشعب
السوري اما ان كل حركه اه تدور في الساحه
العربيه يجب ان يتم انه نسميها ثوره
استثمار او فرضا او واجب ان نسميها الثوره
فانا اعتقد ان هذه التسميات ليست في محلها
على الاطلاق وان هذه التسميات هي سبب يعني
سبب البلاء الذي تعاني منه الساحات
العربيه نعم هناك معارضه نحترم هذه
المعارضه النظام في سوريا يحترم هذه
المعارضه لكن على هذه المعارضه ان تكشف ما
هو برنامج الحقيقي لا ان تخرج بدايه لتقول
ببعض الاصلاحات ثم تتطور عندما يستجيب
النظام الى بعض الاصلاحات المعينه الغاء
قانون الطوارئ قانون تعدد الاحزاب اه
قانون للاعلام وحريه الاعلام ثم الحك
الكلام عن دستور جديد او الغاء الماده
الثامنه في الدستور ثم يبدؤون بتصعيد
تدريجي ويعني يعني يحشدون كل الراي العام
الدولي ثم استهداف للشخصيات الامنيه
والسياسيه والاقتصاديه
التركيز على شخصيات مقربه من الرئيس وان
ال قرابه الشخصيه او العائليه او القرابه
بمعنى ال قرابه ال ال اه يعني قرابه
المنصب كان هناك استهداف ل بعض المؤسسات
الاقتصاديه التي يحاولون من خلالها
الاضرار بالمجتمع السوري والاضرار
بالاقتصاد السوري واخر هذه الابتكارات
العجيبه الغريبه التي خرجت علينا بها
لائحه الاتحاد الاوروبي بان اه السيد رامي
مخلوف عندما كان في الالفين وثمانيه
حاربته الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
انه شخص فاشل وهو يقود يعني اكثر من خمسين
بالمائه من الاقتصاد الوطني في سوريا ثم
الاتحاد الاوروبي جاء ل يكذب هذه الروايه
الامريكيه
ويقول ان السيد رامي مخلوف و اه المساهم
في شركه سيرياتيل الذي يملك نسبه معينه في
سياريتين يجب ان تحارب السير لانها تساهم
في دفع الضرائب اكثر
النظام في سوريا الى السلطان في سوريا اذن
هناك
هناك هناك شركات اخرى على مستوى ال قطاع
الخلوي في سوريا وهي تدفع الضرائب لماذا
لم يطلع
النقطه التي كنا ن اناقشها وهي سلميه هذه
الثوره قبل قليل كنت تقول فيصل عبد الساتر
كان يقول والسؤال انها بانه يرفض ان تسمي
هذه الثوره او توصف بانها سلميه اذا عدنا
الى ظهور بعض ال ال ال ال المظاهر المسلحه
في الشوارع في حمص وفي ادلب و في ريف دمشق
اه فعلا تساءل ان كانت فعلا هذه الثوره
سلميه هناك تفجير حافله جنود هناك بعض
المنظمات المسلحه التي بدات تظهر يعني هذا
ما تتحدث عنه التقارير الوارده من سوريا
فكيف يمكن وصف هذه الثوره بانها سلميه
مائه بالمائه
بس هل تسمعني
لا يبدو انه وضيفنا بشاره اه يسمعني الان
اه بس هل تسمعني
طيب طيب في انتظار ان يتم اصلاح العطل اه
الفني مع بسام جعاره يعود الى بيته بيروت
و فيصل عبد الساتر الان ما هي البدائل
يعني الى اي مدى يمكن ان يستمر الوضع كما
هو عليه الا الثوره نجحت ولا النظام
السوري ايضا نجح في ارجاع واعاده الناس
الى بيوتهم واعاده الوضع الى ما كان عليه
قبل سبعه اشهر
ليس المطلوب ان تعود الناس الى بيوتهم
بهذا المعنى الحرفي للكلمه وليس المطلوب
ان يسقط النظام المطلوب ان يتفق المجتمع
السوري والنظام في سوريا على حل وسط او هو
الحوار الحوار هو السبيل ال ال افيد وال
سبيل ال انجح لحل المشكلات اذا كلما تحرك
في العالم العربي يجب ان يسقط بنظام هنا
وان يسقط نظام هناك يعني نحن امام اه يعني
اه امام بركان هائل لا نعرف ما هي النتائج
الحقيقيه اذا ما استمر ولا اعتقد ان قطر
ستكون بمناى او السعوديه بمناى او
الامارات بمنع انا اعتقد ان كل العالم
العربي سوف يشهد هذه ال ارتجاجات وبالتالي
نتحول الى ساحات فوضى عارمه لا نعرف ما هي
المطالب التي نريدها ولا نعرف ما هي
الخلفيات التي دفعت كل هذا الشعب العربي
الان الى ان يتذكر الى انه محكوم بالحديد
والنار وانه يريد ان يحكم بالمن والسلوى
هذه القضايا لا تاتي في ليله وضحاها
عندما نريد ان نحقق ديمقراطيه يجب ان
نتوقف ديمقراطيا لا يمكن ان اخرج الى
الشارع واطل فلان او فلان ثم اقول اني
اريد ان احصل على ديمقراطيه وحريه للراي
لا اريد ان اهدد على قناه وصال و على قناه
صفا وهدد بمجموعه من الطوائف السوريه اذا
لم يكونوا مع هذه الحركه
الاخرى التي تطرحها الان الى يعني
يعني من من مصلحته الان ظهور بوادر تسليح
هذه الثوره وش يعني التقارير كثيره تتحدث
عن ظهور منظمات مسلحه عن تفجير شاحنه جنود
عن ظهور مظاهر مسلحه في ادلب ريف دمشق وفي
اماكن اخرى
يعني اسمحي لي ما يجري هو بالشكل التالي
هناك جنود يرفضون اطلاق النار على اليا
هؤلاء الجنود يهربون باثنتين الجيش
يلاحقهم فتحدث اشتباكات الثوره كانت سلميه
وهي سلميه الان وستظل سلميه ولكن هل يجب
على الجنود ان يطلقوا النار على شعبهم
هؤلاء الناس عندهم اخلاق هم يرفضون اطلاق
النار على اهلهم على ابناء شعبهم والذي
يحدث ان الامن والشبيحه
يلاحقونهم يعني الجيش الان بات ينكشف
بمعنى ان النظام يسحب الجيش شيئا فشيئا من
الشارع يحل محلهم الشبيحه هو يعرف تماما
حجم الانشقاقات التي حدثت خلال الايام
الاخيره في بدء الق القصه كانت هناك
انشقاقات محدوده خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
وتحديدا خلال الاسبوع الماضي زارت
انشقاقات كبيره من الطبيعي ان يعرف الجنود
باسلحتهم ومن الطبيعي ان تحدث اشتباكات
بينهم وبين من يطاردهم هذا ما يجري الان
في الساحه ولكن اذا انسحب الجيش والامن من
الشارع فمن سنجد هل سنجد من هو مسلح
يعني ايضا من ايه السلاح الجيش العراقي
الان يتوغل في البوكمال وهذه ادانه للنظام
الحدود اللبنانيه محميه الجيش السوري يدخل
الى البلدات اللبنانيه يعني من ايلات
السلاح من البحر شكرا جزيلا لك المجاوره
المعارضه السوريه كنت معنا من لندن واشكر
ايضا فيصل عبد الساتر الكاتب الصحفي
السوري من بيروت بهذا ناتي مشاهدينا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
وراء الخبر غدا باذن الله قراءه جديده في
ما وراء خبر جديد اطيب المنى والى اللقاء
ام